How do you feel?
I know that people make this association
with you because I've seen it when we
have guests come on,
we have a thread on our reddit and
people post their questions and I've
seen it before people associate you with
pandering to like white supremacists or
worse.
I've even seen the suggestion that you
are a white supremace per supremacist
yourself.
So how do you feel about that?
And that's,
that seems to be like a somewhat widely
held.
Well,
I don't want to think about that.
It's completely ridiculous.
Like for example,
I'm the member of A.
I'm an honorary member of a native
American tribe.
I got inducted last year.
I have an Indian name,
a native American name,
like it's completely preposterous and
I've been buying carvings from this like
isolated tribe in northern Vancouver for
northern northern Vancouver Island for
15 years,
you know?
And so and I've had lot might.
Well it's,
it's preposterous.
And,
and I mean the,
the,
there's evidence that it's preposterous
and the evidence is that I have 260
videos on youtube and they must total at
least 600 hours,
something like that.
And you know,
by now people have been over them
essentially with a fine tooth comb.
Virtually everything I've said in my
classes to my students in the last 25
years is on video.
And so if there was anything in there
that was even remotely associated with
that,
it would come out and,
but it's even worse than that because
it's actually the opposite because the
reason I've been teaching students for
since 1993 about the Holocaust and what
happened in the Soviet Union,
you know,
and I've been trying to make them
understand how that's associated with,
with the unwillingness to accept
personal responsibility and educating
them as deeply as I can about the
horrors of,
of,
of exactly that sort of thing.
I could say obsessed me ever since I
was,
while ever since I was very,
very young.
And so not only is it not true,
it's,
it's anti true,
it's seriously untrue.
Right.